I'm talking to mr.
Clary erdman who when he was
a lot younger. He worked on the building
of the sydney harbour bridge in one
section where were you born. Mr. And when
born in dolby queensland. When were you
born there are more in the ten to mine.
Why do you know five weeks if their age.
What was your father my father.
Well he was a teamster. She was
a teamster he passed away when i was
three and my mother married again and
she died when i was thirteen. So i was left
practically an orphan of the storm. But
i've battled around and done did various
works in the country you know gone down
the farms and different things like that
and eventually i went to be toria you got
it all went to victoria and i worked on
different farms there and i got sick of the
country. So i came back
to sydney and i got
a few jobs around sydney labouring in
there. So one day i seen an ad in the
paper wanted men for storage work put in
a new sure he's lying. I don't know i can't
remember whether bondo or broadly any i
went out down i was ten minutes too late.
So i thought i'll while i go back to the
city but on the way
back i thought i'd have
a look at the harbour bridge. So only how
i went down and i was standing at the
gate having
a look around you know to see the progress
and. A cap past me and he said what are
you looking for work and i said
oh yes i am he said hang on
a man that he said might be able to
get you on. So he went away for about
a quarter of an hour and he came back he
said i want you to go up there and see
a man called mr foley when mr.
Foley was like a ride and gang it
was i so any i went up and seen mr.
Foley and i only have an overcoat singlet
on and try our tv pretty poor and them
days so i seen mr.
Foley and he said take off your overcoat
so i'm so i took off me. Overcoat. Oh by
the way i was only about twenty three
years of age then so i took my with the
overcoat an easier ride oh he said put
it down area should go and get it in and
pick up some rivers. So only
are we doing that for quite
a while. And then. By came to me that mr.
Foley came to me and said i
want you to go up there to mr.
Barr. Now it was
a foreman carpenter on the gantries so
any i worked on the gantry for quite
a while and then mr.
Miller that was the superintendent on the
door of point so i. He put me in there
but they call the tenant was
a support sharps that's where the cable
so supportive dishpan in our work and
there for quite
a while and what were you doing there. I
drooling the rock i wear on what they call
an english store brand rock welding machine.
There was quite appeal before if i was
down there in that time was so they were
paramount the powder monkeys name was
kelly i can't think of each
christian name but any hour after
a while i got to have been taking him by
an underground and then i thought i'd have
a look at another job somewhere else. Anyhow.
Excuse me i went onto the approach to
the harbour bridge in
a concrete gang and rambo called charlie
leeds and that was the gang as name so i
worked on bet for quite
a while and finished up leaving it
there when you were on the tunnels.
Were drilling holes vertically or horizontally
to get terrorist copic all. About
horizontal into the rock face. And
how well it was started or they were
down about fifteen feet or twenty feet in
them days. I suppose about what five or
six metres and then how. How
many feet did you go to the end.
How did you go down to the bottom. I dug
in my really and by how far down did you
go about i don't the day over the right
down to the bottom of the tunnel. I think
it was about 240 feet. So you were there
and right the way through until it was
finished. We're going you know not told us
finish now when i got down to the bottom
. I don't that's when i left. I went up 240
for about their day here is what i was
at with the tunnels on that i couldn't
tell you how big round or no they were
square where time on how
many when they were there be
a bigger two through right. Hundred twenty
eight cables but you didn't see the
cables. No i didn't see the cable but
then i left before then what about the
concreting at the bottom. Did you have
it you know i had nothing to do with the
concreting only the drilling of the rock.
And there and did you keep on drilling
all the time and somebody else did the
rock yes i would rather shovelling out
a rock and we were drilling. Four or
five hours on the drill two men to
a drill. You have to hold the drill
up yours is and i have dialed
a drill up in your hand and it was
no stand. Heavy work hard. Or
reasonably hard time but no money would
have good. Good. You could ever want the
money was yes i think it was
£6 twelve and fivepence
a week for about forty hour week
then we were on forty hours. And how
long were you actually there
on those tunnels. I was on
a time on it i suppose to be
eighteen months two years and with
a nearly finished when you
got. Oh yes he's done
a penny. So you would have started what
will be but twenty twenty six twenty six
and twenty seven. I started there
and i was there for about two and
a half three years because the tunnels were
actually put into use in 1928 when the
ice right here. I left about 1927 i
think it was for the early part of 1928
. And you did you go down there and see
that the cables in position later on. Yes i
seen i mean pinned i didn't go down as you
are now but i seen the gable support my
stance span and i yet i i followed it right
through and i don't know what you need
to do come under and that i was on the
oh you no you stray and workers union in
them days. You remember who the
delicate was and i can't think of
a delegate but i think the secretary was
a blow by the name of bodkin
and vodka and was the
work. I mean it was there any precautions
to stop the dust. Now you know we had no
precautions to stop and was not water. I
know. Also you don't want to go through
the drills. As you're drilling those want
to go through the drill. So there was no
dash attached to it at all. There wasn't
dusty down there no no no no doubts no i
was very good. When they got to the
bottom right tell me they dago cut out of
a hole in the bottom because the water
starter seep in. They had pumped on it but i
wasn't there. There was no water running
in from the harbor where you were now. How
are you were there on the digging where
they were dug the skew backs for the
bearings were you. Now you know now. Was
there going on at the time was it was i
think really. Already finished going on
at that time. Verify anything go and they
only charge you know we. After
we got down a certain way
a certain depth. We came to
a concrete and then so they were sell us
where they used to tie the prisoners up in
they had the the rings in the walls and
everything. What was that unless there was
points i didn't notice used to be doors
battery to call game but repeal i
think in them days battery point or
battery you know. So these cells with
a part of the army they'd be part of
the con make things where they put
a convict some of the convicts tied them
up blogger much opposed to being. It was
reims in the war any i suppose haven't how
if i haven't been about twenty or thirty
feet down and nobody knew it was there
before you know and when you. We didn't know
anything today. Photograph it you
know. No i don't think so they
could tell it quite
a while we were going down below but i
didn't know that you know and we were there
were they broke into this place. They
broke through. Yeah broke through yet. It
sounds as if it was part of doors battery.
You know door battery very likely care
if they called
a battery park or battery or something
like that. A long way from my talking head
again. But we all the guns are still up
there. Yeah younis still up me they reckon
. Yeah yeah. So what did you do next after
the tunnels. After that time it was
that's when i went up onto the approach of
the harbour bridge. I worked on that for
quite
a while and where we were birds
were you working where the.
We about 100 yards back from the bridge
from the start of the bridge was the old
old bridge there. Yeah the argyle
catch somewhere around there we were
in that last. No no no
we were concreting after
that yet and i've been so you there when
they built the bridge over the cap and you
know now. Now i left before that. So where
were you exactly were you further back
than that. Further back than that. Here we
weren't in york street area where there
were the railway tunnels we're going
underneath now you know after that between
that and me me the argyle
cut i suppose it'd
be me hard to tell and then days when
you're up there. You didn't know where you
were were you there before there were
there demolished princes street and upper
fourth street. No. Oh no no that you me
know where the school was there to portray
you know are now on the other side. And
i know where you live. It's where did i
live in sydney in st.
Peters you know leapt into beaters and you
get to work or used to go by tram. The
old tram. You said one day
that you that you met dr.
Redfield do you remember that i met him at
that when not when we were working i yes
we met him quite a few of us meeting
in there. You know partying by is just
a good morning doctor. And so was another
one now. I think his name was mr.
Freeman. I only seen him occasionally they
were on he have something to do with the
bridge. I don't know exactly what it was
the doctor if you will come and talk to
you do you know just used to be the time
of the day he was passing that was all you
know we were there when the bridge
the arch was joined now but i seen
a joint early one morning and
you had to wait till the
a certain temperature and
what did you do after that.
Did i do after that after i left
a bridge. And there you got my
oh i joined the tramway. Right.
I joined the tramway when
a tram conductor and you were out of work
after you left the bridge were you i was
out of work for
a little while. And then i was on the
what you comb relief work. Instead to get
madeleine them days you had to go and
do some relief work. You know digging
water channels and out and centennial
park living levelling the sand hills
down and different things like them which
was what you did. Yeah it was hard to
even yes i married. A married couple kiddies
three kids. You married when you were
on the bridge. Yes i would marry when i
on the bridge. You know good money. Here.
And i want me out of work
too long and hard to
say it's so long ago. You can't remember
everything you know because i remember
when i had to go and get the dole where
we have to go down to circular quay and
then we used to go to thomas street up
near the right weight of the benevolent
society. But after that they issued our
tickets when you went to the grocers and if
you were sweet with the grocery if you get
a pack of cigarettes why did hold take it.
But things were very hard. Then they now
i went onto the tram was after that
and after being on the tram as for
a while i decided i didn't
like it. So i went and got
a job in engineering over in glebe and i
decided i'd like to go into the trade so i
went to the technical college for
a while and i learnt the art of oxy in
electrical welding and i joined the
boilermakers union in. Mass to finish
me out till i retired i worked till
i was sixty seven and a half
years of age. So i thought i had
a map. Where did you go to school i
went to school in me in queensland for
a little while. And then i went to
a private school in bexley. Run by the
salvation army. Instead me basically
and so that was when your mother came as
a as right and good at schooling did you
already it'll be good for you to be good
if you like better than i like the our
geography and history and history of
australia especially your
family german extraction. Yes
at my grandmother and grandfather they
came from frankfurt in germany many years
ago over
a hundred years ago i'd say and my mother
and father was they were queensland it
and. So you. You decided
to go to the check out
and you had no trouble with the work
you know now. No no father. I work for
a place course e.c.
Engineering the bridge road to leave. How
did you get in there because you were
over. You must have been twenties by that
time. Oh yes. Whereas when you fly over
something. Oh well the air excepted you
as an apprentice at that time. You didn't
go as
a pianist you didn't go apprentice your
weight is. Just down the court. And you
weren't here you know went and
done a course a volkswagen
a critical wellington and that and
then i went and i was accepted in the
boilermaker union where were you during
the first member of the first world war i
was in can wear my mother and
my stepfather came he was
a commercial traveller and we came to town
worst and i can remember. I can member
1914. When the war broke
out in 1915 i came
down to sydney. The school in bexley. And
that. No i didn't i tell a lie
there. I went to manly the day
a place called book violin manly
and i would say after school for
a while and they shifted to baxley so
that's where i went to school in bags like
what arrangements did they have to make.
To take you to study at the technical
college. I mean i just went
down and put me name down for
a course was the depression and now i know
now that the pressure was established
1937 and. About 1937 you
know more broke out in
1939 i left the trams in 1939 and
and went to work in say she engineering.
So it was the war that made it possible
for you to yet read that all i cared
for where. Possible to get the trade
strike on the tram was oh we're good. You
know way old footboard to you out in
the weather and if it rains. You've
got wet and if it was hot. You've got
overheated so hope you've got
it both ways. Can you remember
any particular jobs that you
do know. I mean after you.
Are no different in different firms
i work furlough i work for i
w edwards building service i work for
archers. And i work for van gelder.
All engineering or welding electrical
welding different equipment hydraulics and
different machine reason things like
that you have any particular jobs.
There's any big jobs it was all
fabricated or fabricating or fabricating
engineering where we're going. So
yeah you know and we work on on
a lot of war equipment bren gun carrying
chavez and mine sweeping equipment.
That was that was about 1940. I went to
join up. But when i went down to the
military barracks they they tore up my
application form and put me on protected
industry. So i never went to
the war. Maybe i might have
been like it. Yeah. You
know when the harbor bridge
was opened there that they know i wasn't
there that day i wasn't there at day but
i heard all about it all the group cut
me the ribbon jack lang hope an up i was
a jack lang man you know i remember. Or
it's going back
a long way. You know you
might have been joke garden.
He was. A what member what sort
of i mean but i mean i knew when
i went as mp i don't i will never know
it might have been john gone took
a long time ago. You can't remember all
these things particularly as you know him i
knew him saving my life. You
know a joke involved with
a magazine you know no no no joke. I'd
want to add up to do with i know you. Were
you involved with the boilermakers union.
No no no i just stay in the ball and i
make the union. Do you remember
charlie brown and charlie
brown
a room with charlie charlie brown he was
apprenticed in the workshops over the north
side. Yes yes. And then he was
a union delegate. That's what i was
asking here. Yes he was a union they have
a good where he was unique alligator and
sydney is in sydney charmless street
. Is there anything else you can remember
about working on the bridge and no other
people who work with. You know i can't
remember any of them now only kelly the
powder monkey. I can't remember any of
their names are now in fact i don't know
whether i had be alive or not. So yea
maybe three now well as i say i was only
about twenty three when i worked on the
harbour bridge and the man i worked with
while they were thirty and forty year old
men so you can just imagine how many of
them would be alive. You can't
think of any juries who might be
a lonely hard time and now now. I can
remember one very his name was lament him but
a bittersweet. He was
a dogman. Was the only bloke i can think
of now. It was an area of island or door
point side he was on the wilson crane you
dog them on one of the little wilson
grange and the wilson cranes where did what
with it was their job they were cotton
timbers along as the gantries went along.
What they they were up on top up on top.
Yes steam with
a steam train yet only if you take used
to take the bags coke up and or up in the
sling. So you would rolled that till now
i wasn't involved with that at all. Now.
So what stage were they when you arrived
there they got those false work. The
oregon falls to before his work was already
up there was it you know i well we were
putting that out
a lot of it with up when i went onto it.
Yes i could call them the gantries. Yet
all twelve twelve. Timbers they were
already oregon timber shares and the
carpenters working on that work. What sort
of equipment were they using what were
they drilling with i think it was
a air drills almost sure it was aired little
bit. The captain was in charge we name
when jimmy bar. Him he was
a foreman and you were often up
there. Did you often go oh yes yes.
Things. Had they started to lay out the
approach spans on top of this timber by the
time you moved from there or not you know
they hadn't put out the approach bandsaws
only the line with the crane running on.
So they were ready to go you know read it
in actually started you know if it was at
that stage you went down the tunnels or
out right as when i went down the timeline
here. So that was very early. I would
think that would be nineteen twenty
six 1926 i think i was about
nine i was nineteen twenty five. I was
twenty nineteen twenty twenty. The
1926. twenty for
the con i'll be 1927 i
think about 1927. So with
a pilot with the apartment towers above
the ground level either pylons were going
up and then days yeah they were concrete
in the pile ten all the all the stonework
that came from
a place called meru you know the quarries
down maria. They used to bring the stone
around an hour and
a boat and i unloaded it underneath. I
guess they aren't allowed it and loaded at
the wharf and they unloaded all the the
gravel fillings. Do you know you know the
crane driver down there. It's you know i
couldn't tell you to crash into i was you
know. Do you have
a crash drivers up on the notice you
know i don't remember them. There's
a lot along on the bridge. You never
knew their name and say there was
a terrible lot of scotchman
a lot of the englishmen that came out
here especial for that work there were
brought out they were there. I don't know
where they were brought out i'm not i
can't remember when i brought out i just
came out on their own bat and i've heard
that
a few maybe ten were but yes other than that
i might have been there and there might
have been foreman boilermakers. And
foreman fitted into even the foreman
boilermaker in the workshops was not
right. He came out and there is
a scene. I brought
a whole whole crew of i think it's about
twenty of them come out. That's right.
Belfast together outright they weren't
brought out by drawing on there and then
there was the martin as i was two brothers
they were in charge of the workshops.
They were englishmen i think yeah english
which later doorman along itself was
there was
a firm from middlesbrough an england and
when you worked on the on the approach
bands concreting on the approaches to the
public works concrete yeah. Was that was
the work harder. Was there or yes
a bit harder feeling because feed
a concrete mixer. We had to put so much
sand so much metal into the concrete mixer
into the hopper and mix it up. It was
poured what was the form in the charger and
like i was not mad. I don't know my
charlie leds and. He'd be dead and gone.
I think i suppose to do with a small
machine is a small ranking which or about
a yard i think held about
a yard where they put their use put the
concrete into it to barrows or that they
use huge chutes issues is they have skips.
Did with you when you tipped to concrete
mixer straight up to shoot it. Yes i would
say you know you came straight out of
a shell yeah yeah. I make sure into the
field. So you move the mixer you make sure
yeah where we have to pour you move you
know your concrete make sure yes and be
able mobile. I understand. And the carpenters
were forming up right there and you
say you have mix was on top of the formwork
was it. That's right yes. On top of the
formwork and shoot straight down. Do you
member of the. Concrete packing in those
days and anybody doing packing. Now i can't
remember you know the reinforcing they
were different crew to last. Was it
really concrete steel. Yes i think it was
around board concrete.
So it was for that with
a time you got there it was already formed
up with it with the steel. Yeah yeah.
Reinforcing it and. There was none
of the barrows businesses right now.
I've got
a photograph of over on the north side
of the music those barriers they call
rickshaws all the elric sure i yeah you
know i didn't see any regular we didn't
have any rickshaws you know all the time.
That's not on that's right. Now shall
rickshaw they were they were hard marriage
and the balance family. Went over the
plank that was the end of it. You went
with it. Did you ever work with shows. I
have work with them but not on the harbour
bridge. Need to heal bearers of. Because
of their bit dodgy you know they were die
you alright respective here working on
planks you had
a plank on each wheel you know under each
wheel and if you missed where you went
with the bower. For the further grass i
actually saw north sydney. They were.
They were doing the lavender street arch.
. A record poor and one
day for right there was
a record poor and they've got these all
these planks up over the top there and
they've got the concrete mixers down one
end and. And they're all about twenty of
them with these regrets your hair just won't
move it along the top and they must be
a hundred feet up with the
air. Yes yes that was
a band so i don't know what side because
it was more hilly on that or shady side
whereas on our side was a
more or less a well quite
a bit hilly but. Coming from like from that
time on us from the city kid you got to
doorways point. While the doors pointed
to the old what they call it now.
Observation park i think they call it now.
Observatory observatory that's right.
Observatory hill and so you were up
near the nearly schoolgirl school. Yes
that's right time ago. Yes. Broad street
and it was already pulled
down the other side
a forgery by the time you got there. All
i know you know for street went on for
many years after that. My daughter went
out for street. I don't mean that i mean
the street. I don't mean the school. I mean
the street or the street and go. Yes i
suppose a straight a girl up a street up
a ford straight yeah. Because the school
was on one side of the street and it was
very much. There were some other things
on the other side and sides even you know
but on the other side of the street was
a full width of the street was pulled down.
Yes. As we are the same as on this on
the doors points right. There was
a three. Yes that was all those two
story houses were all pulled down near
. Yes i remember some of them had been
poured down the princes street that was
pulled out where princes street was pulled
down over there before it was pulled. I
can remember it all yet
i remembered. The rock
a long time before any of that was pulled
down and i waited around the rocks there
for
a while. So what was princes street
like oh is it rough. Or was it and was
always moms around there no
rocks mob and then there was
a wall of mullah omar bin who was there
that sent peter to more but they all mobs
and named days the railway mom of
the forty thieves. It where it
all you know any of these i knew
a couple as i knew couple where was the
forty thieves. Therefore they were redfern
. Yeah well they were nearly all married
men the kids use their fists and they
cleaned up a lot of the
mobs. They cleaned up
a lot of the mobs. What did they do
terrorizing people. Oh yeah oh no. They only
terrorize what i mean to say they
picked their marjorie was my buddy.